こんにちは、変分量子固有値ソルバーコースシリーズへようこそ。
私はVictoria Lipinskaです。このビデオでは、VQEの問題を
量子コンピューターが理解できる形式で表現する方法について解説します。
一般的に、量子化学の問題はシステムのエネルギーを用いて
表現されます。
これらのエネルギーを記述する演算子をハミルトニアンと呼びます。
まず、これを量子化する必要があります。
つまり、量子化学の言語で表現すること、
これを正式に第二量子化と呼びます。
ハミルトニアンがフェルミオンの相互作用を記述する場合、例えば
スピン軌道における電子のエネルギーを表す場合、これを
フェルミオン型ハミルトニアンと呼び、今日の出発点となります。
qubitには、独自の言語があります。
qubitの世界における演算子は、パウリ演算子で記述されます。
ここでの目標は、フェルミオン演算子を
qubit演算子で表現することです。
フェルミオンとqubitの間には、
0と1の状態に関して単純な一対一の対応があります。
そのため、状態間のマッピングも直接的です。
ただし、演算子のマッピングはやや複雑です。
フェルミオン型ハミルトニアンは、生成演算子と
消滅演算子で表現されます。
そのため、量子コンピューターがハミルトニアンを
理解しやすくする必要があります。
フェルミオン型ハミルトニアンをqubit型ハミルトニアンに
gateを用いてマッピングするために数学的なツールを使います。
つまり、量子化学の言語と
量子コンピューティングの言語の間で翻訳を行うわけです。
2つの鎖をイメージしてみてください。一方はフェルミオン、
つまり量子化学の言語で書かれた鎖。
もう一方はqubitによる量子コンピューティングの言語です。
一見すると、このマッピングは簡単に思えますよね？
どちらの場合も、2準位のシステムが見られます。
フェルミオンの場合、状態にフェルミオンが1つ存在するか、
まったく存在しないかのどちらかです。
qubitの場合は、状態0か状態1かのどちらかです。
しかし実際には、それよりも複雑です。
qubitの鎖とフェルミオンの鎖の違いは、
物理学における非常に基本的な性質、すなわち交換対称性にあります。
2つのフェルミオンが同じ状態を占めることはできません。
しかし、qubitの鎖ではこれがまったく異なります。
2つのqubitが同じ状態に同時になることができます。
qubitはフェルミオンではないからです。
2つの鎖の間で変換する方法を見つけなければなりません。
早くも1928年に、JordanとWignerという2人の研究者が、
鎖全体のフェルミオン演算子が
qubit演算子で正確に表現できることを示しました。
これは量子コンピューターにとって最も直接的なマッピングです。
例えば、軌道の占有数を
1つのqubitのスピンにマッピングするために利用できます。
実際には、ハミルトニアンへのこのマッピングにより、パウリ演算子の重み付き和が得られます。
これは非常に重要な事実ですので、覚えておいてください。
次のモジュールで改めてこの点に戻り、
変分circuitが量子コンピューター上でどのように実行されるかについてお話しします。
上記のマッピングが意味するのは、例えば
フェルミオン演算子が14個あった場合、問題を14個のqubitにマッピングするということです。
幸いなことに、qubitの数を減らすための巧妙な方法が存在し、
より少ない量子リソースで量子コンピューターから良い性能を引き出せます。
一般的に、分子系ではハミルトニアンの
物理的な対称性がわかっています。
例えば、電子の総数は固定されています。
この情報を利用して、問題のサイズを
関連する情報を失わずに削減できます。
この手法をアクティブスペース削減と呼びます。
これにより、qubitの数などのリソースを削減でき、
Jordan-Wigner変換のようなqubitマッピングの前に行えます。
このステップで有効ハミルトニアンを計算し、
結果として使用するqubitの数を減らすことができます。
14個の軌道を使った例では、
この手法によりqubitの数をわずか6個に削減できます。
さらにこの削減を進めることができます。
Jordan-Wignerより
少し精巧な別のマッピングを使うことができます。
最もよく使われる例がパリティマッピングです。
パリティマッピングは、軌道の占有数をqubitにマッピングするのではなく、
軌道のパリティを1つのqubitにマッピングします。
ここでは数学的な詳細には立ち入りませんが、
重要なのは、このマッピングにはさらなる冗長性が含まれており、
それを利用してさらに2つのqubitを除去できることです。
したがって、14個の軌道の例では、14 qubitから
アクティブスペース削減で6 qubitになり、さらに4 qubitへ
パリティマッピングの2 qubit削減により減らすことができます。
もう1つの変換についても簡単に触れましょう。
フェルミオン表現とqubit表現の間でよく使われる
別のマッピングがBravyi-Kitaev変換です。
Bravyi-Kitaev変換はqubitを使って情報を符号化します。
占有数と量子状態のパリティの両方についての情報です。
Bravyi-Kitaev変換は占有数とパリティの情報を組み合わせ、
サイズNの分子軌道基底に対して、
やはりN個のqubitが使われます。
ただし、各qubitに格納される情報は
どのqubitかによって異なります。
つまり、qubitのインデックスが偶数の場合は、
対応する軌道の占有数を格納し、
これはJordan-Wignerマッピングと同様です。
qubitのインデックスが奇数の場合、そのqubitは特定の
占有数の集合のパリティを格納します。Bravyi-Kitaev変換は、
qubitの数が2の累乗に近いときに最も効率的です。
Bravyi-KitaevマッピングはJordan-Wignerの利点と
パリティ変換の利点を組み合わせています。
各ハミルトニアン項が作用するqubitの数を減らし、
量子シミュレーションにとって重要です。ハミルトニアン中で
多数のqubitに作用する項は、
シミュレーションにより長いcircuitを必要とします。
つまり、circuit深度が
Bravyi-Kitaev変換によって削減され、一般的に
ハードウェアでより良い結果が得られます。
これはJordan-Wigner変換に対する改善であり、
Jordan-Wignerの場合はN qubitのハミルトニアンのオーダーになります。
このビデオでは、フェルミオン型ハミルトニアンを
qubit型ハミルトニアンにマッピングする手法を探りました。
次のビデオでは、最適な状態の選び方と
変分形式またはcircuitの選び方を見ていきます。
それではまた次のビデオでお会いしましょう。